Hey, what's going on? It's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Monday
morning podcast from Monday,
May 2nd,
2016 and I know,
I always make that joke like, oh
my God, where is the year going?
But seriously guys, seriously,
where the fuck is this year going?
What the fuck?
May 2nd already may fucking second.
But getting ready for the
summer. Um, and the meg,
I'm psyched.
I'm psyched that we're into may cause
may means we're closer to the middle of
July and in the middle of the Jill of
July I will be done writing, you know,
helping to write the second season
of f is for family and then I'm free.
Not really,
but sort of and uh,
I'll have two weeks off
and then I'll freckles.
Rumor has it is going to be doing a,
doing a nice run through Europe. So,
uh, which you might may or
may not start in Ireland.
It's all a sort of loose at this point.
But uh,
we're slugging it out and um, I'm
actually feeling much better by the way.
Thank you for not asking with
my Psi Attica. Sayada can,
it sounds like a fucking speed metal band,
you know, not a good one though, right?
Come see my band cy Attica.
We're going to be down at the
ground round on a Wednesday night.
Okay. Yeah, I'll definitely
see it. All right,
so like you think maybe you could
like bring some people, hey, you know,
I'm going to do what I can. All right, so
is that like, I definitely put you down
dude. Fuck off. I'm, I'll, I'll, if I
get there, I'll get there. All right bro.
Chill. Um, Shai Attica. I'm sorry.
I actually, I got some, I found some new
stretches. I found this fucking guy on a,
on youtube, this doctor who
is just sitting on a yoga mat,
one of these fucking new agey guys,
you know what I mean?
One of those guys that's like straight,
but we're still makes you uncomfortable.
You know those, you know those
straight guys? Like it's straight up.
Gay Guy is not uncomfortable to be around,
but there's a certain kind of straight
guy that's coming off like he's gay,
but he's straight. That is the most
uncomfortable male to be around.
I don't know why.
You know what I mean?
It's almost like they got in between the
teeth and you just can't even hear what
the fuck they're saying.
Do you want to be like,
could you just go and get the fuck
Outta here so I can listen to you?
Is there a word for that?
The Gay Straight Guy.
Um, yeah, Bill, it's called the gay
guy in clock in, in the, in the closet.
Well maybe it isn't some, some guys are
just, uh, some guys are just a feminine.
Yeah.
Some guys just stand there and gym
classes. One person after another,
yeah.
Is called to be on the team
or to stereotype. Right.
This gay athletes was
that guy who played on a,
the big 12 there in Missouri
and then he went to a,
that football team and then he got cut.
There must have been hard to cut him.
Right. All right. How bad is this guy?
You have to suck before we
won't get accused of being
homophobic when we kind of,
you know, that's always in the air, but
that's not what I wanted to talk about.
I'm here to talk about siren at Chi,
but Worcester Centrum,
um, turns out my hamstring was fucked up
so I was doing like the touch your toe
stretches,
which is the exact opposite thing that
you want to do because the nerve is like
pinched or inflamed and you're
just like, you're, you're,
you're not stretching it out. It, I
guess you stretch the muscles really,
so whatever. And usually yet, I don't
know, stretches around the nerve.
I have no idea.
I'd never even heard of this fucking
thing until I had this problem and God
knows I didn't take any
anatomy classes. So, um,
I think when you don't have a nerve issue,
you can then do that Ben. Cause well,
what you're stretching really is
just your muscle, your muscle fiber,
the muscle tissue.
Um,
and the nerves are just
sort of chilling around it.
But when it gets pinched between the,
the fucking interior crucial ligament of
the lower fucking vertebrate tailbone,
whatever the fuck it is all
in, I was like, fuck it.
Fucking pulling a balloon. Um,
uninflated balloon.
I have no fucking analogy.
I don't know what Ellie
I know is it hurts.
So I put this guy on this hippy
guy and he was just like, yeah man,
what's she actually want
to do is you don't they,
there's certain stretches did you want,
did you and your certain stretches
that you don't want to do and you know,
we're in an age right now.
It's, I'm so fucking impatient.
I was trying to skip ahead by
just had to sit there, you know,
everything I could do just to
get through a nine minute video.
It's only nine minutes out of my day,
but there's like a flat screen TV
with NBA and Nhl playoffs going on.
I got other videos I can click on.
You know,
as I'm sitting there trying
to listen to this guy,
I'm also looking at all the videos on
the right, you know, there's free porn,
there's all kinds of shit in this guy is
just sitting there going, you know, okay,
could, could stretch it. You
want to do is is actually,
if you should sit down on your buttocks,
make sure your weight is on your,
your pelvic bones. And it was just,
it was driving me fucking insane,
but whatever.
I ended up doing the stretches and I,
and I definitely feel better. So, um,
thanks to that guy,
whatever his fucking name is and I will
definitely be posting those in case
anybody else has that problem.
If you just sitting down in a chair
and like your feet go numb and shit,
you could possibly have what I have.
Oh, you got a big dog sitting
in your lap, one or the other.
I have no fucking idea, but I'm just
happy that it, uh, that it feels better.
And um, I got to tell you all these
fucking aches and pains that I'm having.
I knew this a long time ago.
There's nothing better than stretching
now that I've gone out and I bought all
this fucking rogue fitness
shit. Um, you know,
to lift weights and all the atomic grips
and all that shit to do the a Ninja
warrior stuff. The best thing
I could be doing all that shit.
That shit's all gonna be great.
Provided I fucking stretch. But, um,
I dunno. I wish I knew way, way, way,
way fucking back in the day to stretch.
There was no stretching in the 80s
he went to Gold's gym.
You just did the old,
you know you did the stretch you did
before you started lifting and Gold's gym
back in the 80s you remember fucking
Chevy Chase when he's about ready to jump
in the pool of Christie Brinkley where
he's going. This is crazy. This is crazy.
This is crazy. You know he's moving
his fucking, that's what you did.
You did a couple of those
and then he did like,
you stuck your arm to the side and
you did those fucking, you know,
touch your left hand or your right
toe and up and down, you know,
one to fucking those military things.
One,
two, three, four. Ah, Love
Marine Corp you do on that shit,
right without stretching and then
you would just fucking work out.
I fucked up myself so much. Fucked up my
tricep. I tore a peck, you know, you know,
it's funny.
All of this shit's going to come back
to haunt me the next time I lose my
fucking eye.
Health insurance is someone just listening
to this podcast and list everything
that I'm talking about is some
sort of preexisting condition.
MMM.
You know, you probably go
home, Bill, you're doing well.
How do you keep losing your
health insurance? Well,
because you'd do an acting gig.
They pay you one time and then they start
sending your residual checks for like
a dollar 35 and you have to make 10
grand a year minimum to keep your,
uh, every single year.
You've got to make it.
You got to make that or something like
that to keep your fucking sag after
fucking health insurance.
And uh, you know,
if one year goes by and
you're writing a show,
rather than being on the show, you fucking
lose your a, you end up losing. I mean,
I do anyways.
I haven't done it
enough. Uh, you know,
I haven't done enough act
work, I guess. You know,
you'd think with 58 fast and furious,
47 Friday the 13th you'd think I could
catch on enough to make 10 grand a year.
You know what? I'm blaming the fuck it
after. Sag Health, health insurance.
I think I got to take this. Why?
I've gotta take this one myself.
I got to look myself in the fucking
mirror and be like, you know what bill?
It's your goddamn faults.
Your own fucking fault.
Not you just go out and
get blue cross blue shield.
That's what I should do and I should
just walk away from sag after. Right.
I don't fucking know. I'm a
big advocate of that. You know,
looking yourself in the mirror and
being like, all right, you fucked up.
As opposed to being like, you
know, the world is unfair,
which everybody knows it is.
Right. But if you say, all right,
I fucked up and it actually
gives you an option to be, okay,
what can I do to lessen the fuck up?
Because I know I'm going to fuck up again.
You know, like if you're like
Caitlyn Jenner right now,
rather than fucking filming yourself
taking a Piss and Trump's tower, you know,
why don't you just look yourself in
the mirror and be like, all right,
how did I fuck this up? You know,
for the first 66 years of my life,
I had a definitive bathroom to go into.
There wasn't any questions,
nor did I have to fill myself. And then
afterwards say, I didn't molest anybody.
What has happened to that person?
You know, that, that, that,
that person is absolutely
lost their fucking mind.
Who's walking around filming themselves,
taking a Piss and then
talking about child molesters.
And I know what people were saying,
Oh,
you can't have these fucking a
former guys with boobs now they have,
you know,
if you know that transitioning people,
they'd get a fucking molests somebody,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
I know that that's what that whole
fucking thing was supposed to be about.
But you know,
I dunno,
that just came off to me is
shameless self promotion.
I don't have anything against
transgendered people, but
that's fucking Ding Bat.
It's funny, you see the big bet is
the proper word because you know,
she identifies with the female sex of I
think ding bet now works as opposed to
Douche bags. See, I kept the
D, I went, I went alliteration
ice kid. Never fully see.
You know what?
I,
I would never call Bruce a douche
bag cause he was on the Wheaties box.
You know, I don't know about this Katelyn
though. That's the jury's still out.
Oh Bruce did kill somebody.
You don't accidentally,
Caitlin has yet to accidentally
killed somebody. So you know,
there's a lot of mass to be done. You
know what? I strike all that, I think.
I think, uh, she was right to film
yourself peeing in a skyscraper.
Okay.
You know,
whenever I see a video like that,
I always wonder if people who are
truly suffering around the world,
if they ever get access to a laptop
and just somehow that comes up on their
fucking youtube page,
you know what I mean?
They're just living like in like those
people that like Brazil that live in
those fucking trash heaps.
If somehow they see fucking
Caitlyn Jenner walking around
acting like a victim, you know,
wearing shoes that they probably fucking
sewed together at three o'clock in the
fucking room
morning.
Oh, I know. I know. You're supposed
to care about everything. Um,
I don't, I don't give a fuck. You know
what I give a shit about right now?
Cheyenne? Anika calming
to the Providence. Oh,
so Wurster providence civic
center. Wooster Civic Center. No.
Okay.
Ah, fuck. I can't even remember.
That's all I give a shit about.
I give a shit about, um, I don't know,
being able to fucking reach
down and pick up a dirty sock.
Don't have enough fucking bolt of
lightning. Go down the back of my leg.
That would be nice. Right.
Maybe I'm transitioning,
I'm transitioning into a fucking old
man right before my very eyes, you know,
my fucking dog has just been, he just
sleeps all damn day. It's unreal. I know.
I always bring this shit up,
but it just blows me away.
I want you around the block.
That's it. It's all there was.
Um, anyways, so I've been
watching as much as I can. Um,
my wife's been on the road so I,
uh, I immediately become a, a,
a bachelor. However, I've kept
this place pretty clean, you know,
and that's a very important thing to do
when you're married is when your spouse
leaves, you have to fucking show
them that you can live without them.
I think that's a huge fucking thing.
Like she so wants to come home and just
see this fucking place in absolute like
see that you couldn't live without me.
You know what I mean? Which I couldn't,
I would be fucking devastated
if she fucking left or anything.
Obviously I would be,
but you know what I mean?
You do have to have a
little bit of self esteem.
So I've gone back to the way I used
to live. Like I have one plate,
one fork,
that's all I'm music and I just put it
in the sink and if I need another one,
I just watched that one. That's
great. It's nice and quick.
Saves a lot of water.
Right?
Ed Begley Jr would be so fucking happy
with me right now. One plate, one fork.
I'm really into that type of shit.
And that's very hard to be into
that type of shit when, uh,
when you have a woman in your life,
you know, not having a lot of stuff
because, uh, bitches be like and stuff.
I don't know what it is.
They can't get enough for fucking Amazon.
I wonder what percentage of people,
and you know, this sub fucking guy,
but that doctor did a feminine straight
doctor that helped me with Sayada.
Um, I bet he's on Amazon
all the time, you know,
trying to find a new pair of
fucking puffy pants to sandals. I'm,
isn't it amazing that this guy
helped me out the way he did?
And I'm so fucking damage to the human
as a human being that I still have to
make fun of him.
MMM.
And well, you know, what would
you want from me? So anyways,
the update with the gym.
All right,
I'll actually show you guys before
and after pictures when, uh,
when I'm done because, uh,
it's just a fucking garage.
I don't give a shit if you see that.
So I got the pegboard up.
MMM.
I actually, what I had before
was, you know, those, um,
you know those really long pegboards
where your arms are really close together
and they're like,
they go on for fucking ever.
MMM.
You know, my garage, you know, he has
like a fucking eight foot ceilings,
so that wasn't an option. So I bought
two of those and mounted them sideways.
So I used to just,
just do the pegboard exercise sideways.
You don't try to go all the way
down and then come all the way back.
And I'm now where they moved him,
they actually cut them in half
and put all four side by side.
So the goal is eventually
to go up one down the other,
up the third and down the fourth. I
got that up, I got the speed bag up.
Uh, that's more for my wife.
She's into that shit. Um,
I don't give a fuck about
that. You know, that's always,
that was a big thing when I was growing
up, having a heavy bag and all that shit,
you know?
And then people thought they were tougher
because they were hitting the heavy
bag that has no fucking arms or legs.
You know, you basically just, you,
you beaten up,
you know,
you basically practicing to
fight a cripple is all you
are really doing. I mean,
granted there was cardio involved,
but actually I remember a long time
ago seeing a fucking guy with no arms,
no legs as a wrestler and nobody
could beat him. They just,
there was nothing to hook and
he and he would just do it.
I don't know what he was doing, but he
would somehow flip these. It was like,
can you just imagine wrestling
just a rock, you know?
But it was a long flat one and
somehow it fucking could move.
I don't know.
And it had a head on it.
I don't know how to describe this fucking
kid. All I know is he was winning.
So maybe, maybe there is something about
that. You know, what, can I backtrack?
I don't think I've had one at one point
that I've made in this entire podcast
that I haven't, I haven't
retracted from, well you know what,
it's a fucking election year.
MMM.
What's the guy was, who was the other
guy run other than Donald Trump?
Hillary Clinton. Kidding.
Ted Cruz. Ted Cruz. I don't
know anything about Ted Cruz,
but evidently he's really interested
about where Caitlin Jenner drops a fucking
deuce and Caitlyn made a fucking oh,
snapchat fucking video of right.
Is that what happened? Is that what
happened on fucking Facebook this week?
I'm so out of the loop.
Everybody so out of the loop.
Just can you guys just ride with me for
the next couple of fucking months as I
spend my entire waking hours
in a fucking writer's room.
I don't fucking see anything.
I don't read anything.
We just stare at a computer screen.
I'm going to need fucking glasses
by the time I'm done with this shit.
My Act is drying up.
Thank you.
Know what I'm sitting is
shitting on Caitlyn Jenner.
Thank God she fucking made that video
cause I ended up getting a great bit out
of it this weekend. I fucked
it up the first time. Um,
and then the next time
it, it, uh, it worked. So,
uh,
that's always great. You know,
you gotta Love Topical Material.
Topical material is like the Doritos of
fucking stand up. You know what I mean?
It's fucking,
it's so fucking satisfying.
But there's just no
nutrition in it whatsoever.
MMM.
But anyways, like I was saying
before, I went down to the, the, uh,
the comedy store and Doodie Kenny,
I can't fucking believe it
looks like a Goddamn nightclub.
There's all these young people in there,
there's beautiful women all dressed
up and shit. Just having a great time.
Like it's like, I don't know, I wasn't
around during the 80s, but I don't know.
Um, I dunno how it could have been any
better just as far as the sheer amount of
people coming out in there.
And they are laughers too.
So if you are in the La area,
mmm.
It's a good time to go down there.
And, um, I was on, you know,
the shows I was on was just fucking one
monster fucking comic after another.
That's probably another reason.
MMM.
Like one of my favorites,
I consider a new guys,
Chris Delea who goes down there.
And what I love about that guy
is just as a standup comic,
I love seeing a legitimate headliner.
You know,
there's a lot of people that can sell
tickets because they're on TV or they did
a movie thing or they took a piss and
Donald Trump's fucking tower, right?
Caitlyn Jenner,
which sell out a fucking Improv.
But there's very few people that could
basically follow anybody go out there and
really level like the, the, the,
the point at which that you have to
level to really be considered a fucking
headliner. And, uh, this
guy fucking does it. So, um,
yeah,
man,
there was a bunch of people who the fuck
was on the show and went on up to Dane
Cook. He fucking murdered. Um,
I got there late on that one.
And then the next show I
was working with Chris Delea
and um,
Natasha Leggiero was on Bobby Lee,
by the way, speaking to Natasha.
Did anybody see the new dice clay fucking
series? I love it. Did you see age?
Oh my God, I'm a fuck up.
His name is Adrian Brody.
Why don't I know anybody's name?
He did this whole fucking thing where
he was playing himself and he was, uh,
you know, and in his next acting
role was to play dice clay,
Andrew dice clay in a bio pic.
So the whole episode,
he's trying to get dice that, I don't
want to ruin it, just fucking watch it.
His dice clay is his fucking tremendous.
And um,
I don't know,
speaking of the Worcester Centrum,
I've always been a huge
dice clay fan and I saw him,
I know I've told this story before,
but that's where I saw him in like 1988.
I saw him, uh, at the
Worcester Centrum, um,
with an unknown Eddie Griffin opening up.
And uh,
it was sick. He fucking murdered. He
did a drum solo at the end of the end.
It was one of the sickest
shows I ever saw. And uh,
I still didn't realize that I wanted to
be a comedian, so fucking dumb. I was,
when I was growing up,
do you know,
I used to memorize comedy albums and I
would ride around my bicycle, you know,
doing my paper route,
reciting those at those albums,
pretending I was doing them in the,
in the school auditorium in
front of the entire school.
And it's still never dawned on me like,
hey bill,
that probably means that you want
to be a comedian. Like I never,
it never fucking done, it seemed like
it was a million miles away. You know,
we didn't have youtube,
you know,
could just film yourself taking
a shit at a dairy queen and say,
take that presidential candidate that you,
you couldn't fucking do
that back then. Um, anyways,
so as always I'm going to
talk about another car that
I like and that I probably
will never buy.
I was watching something on that Tesla
s and it's like the self driving fucking
car and these two guys computer,
look at guys,
I'll say that because
they both had glasses.
So if you have glasses in my world that
means you're smart and a lot of people's
world that meets that you know, but you
know I want to be politically correct.
Maybe they were both a couple of fuck
heads but anyways they were in this car
and uh,
they put on the self driving mode and
according to the video they put blankets
over themselves and
they took a fucking nap.
Now Tessa said that there's some alarming
youtube videos of people doing shit in
their cars that you're
not supposed to be doing,
but they basically took a nap and then
somebody wrote in one of the comments
underneath it like, would you get
arrested if you got shit faced,
put it on self driving mode
and then sat in the back seat.
Okay.
And you don't make, you don't know
me, maybe you're thinking on me,
but I'm always bitching about technology.
I actually am coming around
to the self driving car.
Just provided that you could
still drive it if you want to. Um,
cause that is dead is pretty
fucking cool. Do you realize, wow,
how fucking artist shape in like the,
you know,
how bad like this is going to be
for procrastinators, you know,
the fact that they no longer have to
drive themselves to work and they're going
to be trying to finish their fucking
presentation in their car. You know,
you've seen people brushing their teeth
or just people literally with an eye
mask on,
just fucking sleeping in the jam
jams and then they pull up to work.
You know,
like you set your car alarm and that's
like your fucking alarm to wake you up.
Like when it stops and it's in park,
you know,
maybe the horn just goes bad, bad, bad.
That'd be too jarring. That'd be too
jarring for people in the future. Right.
They don't want to fuck a
deal with anything. They just
want to lay around. Right.
So they fucking let you lay
there in the car. And uh,
you know those fucking creepy
self vibrating fucking seats.
When you get too close to something,
maybe it does that you just lay in there,
right? And it just sort of shakes you a
little bit and some weird creepy computer
voice. She could pick
the voice too, right?
You don't got no celebrities
will jump all over that.
They do the fucking voiceovers to make
a little bit of cash because no one pays
for movies anymore. And they're just
sick of being in those mighty heroes.
Fucking superhero movies,
one after another.
They're literally out of ideas.
I mean,
once you have like the superheroes
fighting each other that they gotta be
nervous in Hollywood just going like,
where, where do we go from here?
You know,
can we reboot this thing again? Can we
reboot the fucking joker and all that?
We know what the funny thing is though,
is people will keep showing up.
I guess that makes sense,
right?
God knows they've had the comic books
forever and people keep reading those.
You know what, I'm, I'm taking that one
back. I'm wrong about that one again.
Have I been right?
Fuck.
Bunch of swings and
misses. Um, so anyways,
that Tesla as has another feature where
you can like call the car like a fucking
dog. Like if it's in a tight
parking spot, you can just go,
hey, Tesla, Tesla, Tesla, buddy.
You want to go for a
drive? Right. And, uh,
the thing just slowly backs up.
It comes to you. It's literally,
it's like the fucking nitrite or car.
And like I said,
I am usually anti-technology and um,
but every once in a while
something comes along and I,
and I even meet as much as of a
fucking freckled content. I am,
I have to sit back and be like, you know
what? That's cool. So here's the thing,
the car costs like, I
don't know, like $120,000.
So I imagine 90% of the people,
you know,
not trying to talk down to you,
okay,
we'll say 80% of you that listened to
this fucking thing, right? Just went like,
oh Geez, I'll never be able to afford
that. Yeah, you will. I'll tell you why.
Okay. I'll give you, I'll give you
fucking three examples. Calculators,
rollerblades and flat screen TVs, all
of those things. When they came out,
they were fucking ridiculously expensive.
And then by the end of it,
they gave him away with like
a free tank of fucking gas.
Well maybe not the fucking flat screens,
but you remember like we'll go back to
California calculators first came out,
they were a $100 each, something
crazy like that. And then they,
they just kept dropping,
dropping, dropping, dropping,
dropping is more and more people bought
them and then they had the solar ones in
.
The next thing you know you
got a calculator with the
fucking free Philip at the
gas station. Roller blades were
always over 100 bucks, right?
And then everybody had
them and then they're like,
well what the fuck are we going
to do with the rest of them?
And next thing you know,
they was 30 bucks, right?
Flat screen TVs when they first came out.
I F I for some reason remembered them to
be about 11 grant when they first came
out, you know, and they were
about as thick as my fucking head.
Let me look this up here.
Original price, original price
of flat screen TV's.
I'm saying 11 grand for that screen.
Flat screen falling costs of flat screens.
Wait, a farm, Jesus Christ. I'll
never find it. Oh, the price was
14,090, almost 15 grand,
$999 for a plasma TV,
plasma display, TV, Yada,
Yada, Yada. Advantages,
disadvantages.
Where the fuck was it history to,
we'll go to the two thousands,
2000,
the 40 inch TV cost. Uh, you know what?
Go Fuck Yourself.
I don't know where the fuck or was it
actually came up and then I clicked on it
and then the inflammation disappears.
Um, sorry about that. I'm just so,
I bet that the Tesla,
that technology
will, will, you know, it's like when
airbags first came out, they run Mercedes.
They protected the rich people first.
And then once they got all the rich
people's money, then they go, all right.
You know what?
Maybe we'll protect the middle class
and then eventually it gets all the way
down to like, you know, like
there's starving kids in Africa.
They probably have roller blades,
you know what I mean?
And like a Chicago Blackhawks 2016,
uh,
advanced to the second round
tee shirt. Right. You know,
they always get those fucking
get those hats.
Like Boston Red Sox,
1986 world series champions.
It's always somebody dig in for a blood
diamond where in that shit buffalo bills
four in a row, you know, that's like
what is sexual a tee shirt, you know,
sexually adwares over and fucking done
on one of those sex slave countries.
Are you making light of the sex
trade and no, I'm just talking.
I'll make in front of
the buffalo bills there.
I feel for the person that has two
was sold into sex slavery, but I,
I don't feel bad for the uh,
buffalo bills. You know what I mean?
You know why they lost all four of those
cause nice guys finish last and Marv
Levy is everything that Pete
Carroll looks like he is.
Pete Carroll is is Marv Levy 2.0 both
of them just look like you could just
trust them. You know, I could leave, I
can leave a stack of fucking cash here,
right in front of him. My life savings, I
will come back and I'm going to be fine.
And, and that is true with Marv Levy
and that's why he lost four Superbowls.
Now if you were to leave that with Pete
Carroll, you know, I, I'm, you know,
I don't think I have to tell you that.
You know,
there'd be some Hooters chicks over there
and teach God wing sauce on his face
and be like, it's all there.
Fuck you talking about. Um,
why am I shitting on Pete Carroll
and what you think of bill,
what about your coach? What about fucking
now, what about bill Belicheck? Well,
he doesn't look wholesome.
It looks like a mean dad
doesn't eat like dad's home.
God, he's such a Douche, you know,
that's, that's what he looks like.
Pete Carroll looks like, you know, be
carrot. Looks like he goes to church,
you know,
and on the third day,
Jesus will rise again and
then he's in the back and go,
Woo,
that paid. He always gets excited
during that part of the Jesus Story.
Oh, JJ. Um, oh,
what the fuck was with that guy?
You know,
I actually tweeted about that guy in
the draft that got busted, you know,
wearing in the fucking gas mass,
taking the fucking we'd hit and uh,
everybody gave me shit. Fuck, you
didn't watch the draft. It's like, dude,
it kind of became, it
went viral. Actually. Uh,
I was actually texted to me by a, uh,
another comedian was letting me know.
They said in real time this guy
was getting blackmailed and uh,
I ended up watching the clips do that was
that guy should fire his fucking agent
yesterday. That poor bastard, nobody,
he had no advice. He was sitting there
sweating. If nobody came out, it's,
that woman didn't say, hey,
that's enough. No more questions.
If she didn't rescue him,
that guy would still be sitting
there like pouring sweat,
answering ever every fucking
question that they asked them.
What's the most fucked up
thing ever jerked off to?
Well I would have to say, uh,
you know, it's just like, I don't
know where his agent was, but um,
he was somewhere high
fiving himself I think. Um,
God dammit that Tesla's a good
looking car from the side.
I just hate the front end.
It's just weird, you know,
cause it doesn't need a fucking,
doesn't need a grill cause it doesn't
have a radiator because it doesn't have an
engine to fucking, you
know, cool off or whatever.
I was going to say, well it'd be cool
if they just put it in there anyways,
but then air would get trapped and then
it was actually slow down to that's the
fucking car. That's the car you
want. That thing is, it's fast.
It's actually beats a fucking Lamborghini.
It beats a Ferrari zero to 60.
It fucking smokes. That car
literally smokes a fucking supercar.
Now when they get up into the higher
gears, this, you know, fucking 70,
80 miles an hour, the Ferrari
overtakes them. Who gives a fuck?
Yeah.
Gives a fuck 80 90 miles an
hour. I mean, I guess if you,
the only reason to want a car going
that fast, if you take it to the track,
if you fucking drive a hundred
miles an hour on a regular streets,
you're a fucking asshole and you're
going to kill somebody. So, um,
you know what? God dammit, I think
I'm going to get that car. Uh, Jesus.
That's a good looking car and get it in
black. Huh? With the red fucking cow.
Nah, I'm too fucking, I'm too frugal.
Can't blow her 120,000. What are they?
What's the fucking car payment on that?
It's a fucking moron.
You could buy a third of Detroit for the
amount of money you're going to pay for
a fucking Tesla. That's insane. You know,
I watched the trashiest fucking youtube
videos and I really have to stop doing
it because everything like I,
for some reason I was looking at the
top 10 inappropriate police officer
pictures posted online.
And then once you do that,
then you're just stuck in this thing.
Top 10 things banned in the United States.
Inappropriate family photos that
will make you cringe. You know,
most of them are staged,
but you still sit there and watch at the
top 10 fucking creepy things ever dug
up. The top 10 weird things
in the background is some
Hor took a picture of her
fucking ass in a thong. 10 most
dangerous gangs in the world. All right,
I'll look at this guys. All fucking
tattooed up holding the baby.
As far as for sentence,
10 of the most dangerous
gangs in the world.
This is what I do when
my wife's out of town.
I watch playoff hockey
and then I have that on.
And then I fucking sit here
and I look at this shit.
15 most poisonous animals in the world.
You know what it is?
I've seen every fail video at this point.
I've seen every people are awesome video.
Um,
I've seen every fight video.
I've seen every instant Karma bully thing.
I, I've, I just, I just feel like I've
seen everything that I give a fuck about.
Instant Karmas fails five most
dangerous people in the world.
10 acts, 10 acts, 10 actors
who actually did it on screen.
I didn't see that.
Wait a minute.
What the fuck is this one c and now I'm
not going to watch the most dangerous
gangs. You know, it's funny. As much.
Most of you will make fun of
me right now on the other.
The rest of you are googling
the shit right now. Um,
so anyways,
uh,
see if I got any questions that my fucking
Andrew sent me the fucking questions
yet cause I don't have any of the
advertising. I ain't get nothing.
I'm trying to get this shit out of the
fucking way because I got to do a radio
tour next week to hype all my
dates coming up in Florida. Bill,
you coming to Florida? You
didn't mention that. Oh yeah,
go on all the big cities too.
I'm going to a Orlando right
home of Disney world now.
Like that small shit out here, right?
Just Disneyland. This is Disney world.
Uh,
May 6th I'm going to be at the Seminole
hard rock hotel and a casino in
Hollywood, Florida. Then I'm going to
be at the hard rock live in Orlando,
Florida doing two shows.
And then on May 8th,
I'll be at the Times Union Center
for the Performing Arts, more in
Moran Modal Theater in
Jacksonville, Florida. Um,
and hopefully I'll get
their fucking early enough.
I can go to a gun range in suits
and fucking guns with silences.
That's some fun shit. Um, God dammit.
That's a good time. Jacksonville
is underrated under fucking
rated city to go to,
I know a lot of people shit
on, you know, northern Florida.
But, uh, I gotta be honest with
you. I love a shit town. You know,
there's fun to be had.
Anybody can go to fucking Miami,
go to some fucking Botox party,
whatever the fuck it is
those people do down there.
It's like you're not pretty enough.
You gotta fucking laminate your face.
You know, they're just weird. I like
being in those, you know, Tampa,
Clearwater, Tallahassee, Orlando,
Jacksonville. Orlando is not
even bad. Orlando's like,
I'm sort of like Orange County.
It just sort of a,
I dunno, it has that
mcmansion vibe, you know? Um,
I don't know,
but a lot of people live out that way
because there's no a state income tax.
That's why so many Burt Reynolds ended
up going out there. Oj Simpson, you know,
all the people that had rough course
cases, you know, double murders, divorces,
all of that shit. You know, they all
end up in Florida. That's when you know,
you know, you know, as you get fucking
older, I think he just, that's,
that's one of the major signs that you
were basically a very successful but
married.
The wrong person slash maybe
killed somebody is you end
up in Florida if you're
not like indigenous to that
area. Ooh, bell indigenous.
Somebody learned a fucking
word, Huh? All right.
Let's see if I can read some
advertising here for the Goddamn Week.
The God damn week of May 2nd. You
know, I always make like a, um,
a mental note to myself,
uh, at the beginning of May,
even though I live out here in la in
the fucking weather's always great cause
like I'd always just remember like I
always be working and I'd be site that was
may.
And then before I realized that it was
in the August and I was thinking like,
wow, the first light,
90 days of this shit.
Yeah.
At least May and June.
I think people,
a lot of people take me in
juvenile June for fucking granted.
MMM.
[inaudible]
I mean, I don't know who I'm
even speaking to at this point.
Does anybody really even
have four seasons anymore?
But if you still live in an area like
this is the time where you gotta be like,
all right, let's make the most of
the decent weather. All right. Okay.
Enough with that shit. Let
me read some of the, uh,
some of the advertising here for this
week. All right. Sherry's berries.
Mother's Day is this weekend
only xx days away. Well,
I guess I'm supposed to fill that in
while I'm reading this on a May 1st.
So it's seven days away. It's,
um, it's May 8th this year. Uh,
there was no one quite like your mom.
Every mom is unique and we wouldn't
want to change the thing. Uh,
talk about your mom or your wife's corks.
Funny stories or sayings.
Oh, yeah. Uh, let's see. Uh, I
never tell my mother when I'm on TV
because she's a mom and no matter what
I do, she's going to give me shit. Ah,
you know what? I don't understand
why you wore that shirt.
I liked your performance on Conan
better than on the tonight show.
Um, no, I love my mom, but you know
what I mean? She, she is like, she's,
she's my original like Twitter
troll my entire life. Well,
one of the reasons why I'm so driven is
to just one day have a show or a fucking
whatever, whatever the fuck
he called, doing a talk show,
a segment on a talk show.
We're wired to wire. She actually
goes like, you know what?
I sat down and I watched it and I don't
have a problem with anything you did.
You know, I dunno. Anyways, that's my mom.
I'm going to send some fucking chocolate.
Strawberries are way and with
mother's Day, just around the corner.
I have a great way to show mom how
you appreciate her surprise mom with
something unexpected and as unique as
she is with Sherry's berries right now.
Sherry's berries,
freshly dipped strawberries starting
at 1999 plus shipping or a double the
berries for just $10 more.
This is an exclusive offer to my listeners
or for people with like stepmothers.
You know,
you'd double the berries and then you
split the load and go to Barry's dot com.
Click on the microphone at the top
right hand corner and type in my code,
burr Barry's dipped in milk,
white and dark chocolaty goodness,
topped with rich chocolate chips, chopped
nuts and signatures. Swizzled huge,
fresh, juicy, delicious.
You pick the delivery date you want and
it's guaranteed customer satisfaction is
always guaranteed or your money back.
It's a win win.
Just click on the microphone in the top
right hand corner and type in burpee.
You are, uh, go to [inaudible]
dot com B e r. R. I e. S.
Click on the microphone and
enter my code named birth.
This is a limited time offer and
mother's Day is this weekend,
so make sure you order now.
Uh, it's a great thing to
do. You know, it's your mom.
Don't just give her a phone call.
Give her the chocolate strawberries.
You know what, how about Yoast will give
her a little little bouquet of flowers,
half with pro flowers. Um, evidently pro
flowers is also aware that mother's Day,
this weekend, only fucking eight
days or seven days away, six days.
When you hear this, mom has always
been an expert on everything. Cooking,
relationship advice,
stand up comedy.
I'm fixing your cuts and bruises. The
one thing you can't go to her for, Eh,
for advice on is a what to get
or from others day. Not to worry.
You're going to look like an expert.
This mother's Day when you
use profiles plus pro flowers.
Get Mom 100 blooms with a free glass vase
for 1999 plus shipping and handling or
make her day extra special and upgrades
where premium vase and add a gourmet
chocolate and are at gourmet
chocolate for just nine 99 more.
All shot fired.
Pro Flowers is coming
in and Sherry's berries.
Go to proflowers.com today and and use
my code burr pro flowers are guaranteed
to be fresh and beautiful for at
least seven days of your money back.
You choose the delivery date you want
and it's guaranteed. It's a no brainer.
Here is the only way to get a hundred
blooms with a free glass vase starting in
1999 visit pro flowers.com click the blue
microphone in the top right corner and
type in [inaudible].
That's proflowers.com click on the
microphone and top and type in Burr.
Mother's Day is this weekend, so
order now. Time is running out.
This offer expires Friday at midnight.
All right,
well we've got three more,
so let's get three out of the way and
we'll have two left. All right. Mian aw.
Boto boop, boop, me undies, me on Ds.
No more sweaty balls. Boudou Dude,
do me undies.
Me On the stick them in a bathroom stall.
This Sunday is mother's Day. Get our
pair of panties. What do you say?
It's not too creepy unless you think
about it. Why did I sing about that?
I don't know. Uh, get some fucking me
on these. Yeah. All right. Mandy's,
whether you were with,
they were almost went off the rails,
whether you're wearing a suit or sweats,
you spend almost 24 hours
a day and your underwear,
but instead of making a statement like
Superman's tights under his everyday
clothes, your underwear's probably boring
me on Ds is here to change that. Yeah.
MMM.
Every pair of me on these is made from
sustainably sourced modal Madel Moodle
fabric dads is twice as soft as cotton.
Nothing could describe the fit and feel
of me on undies. But once you try him on,
you'll understand why they're called the
most comfortable goddamn mother fucking
underwear in the world.
And that is a quote.
And if you don't love your first
pair of me, undies are free,
no questions asked me.
And he says dozens of styles and limited
edition prints to help make you make a
statement. How'd you like that
Dick? You like dead Dick Curtain.
Um, and make with your underwear. Well,
whether anyone can see them or not.
Remember Superman. All right. This
is the offer or call to action here.
Shipping is free,
the U S and Canada and you can save up
to $8 a pair with me on the subscription
plan plan. Uh, get the
subscription or a single pair.
Get $20 off your first order.
When you go to [inaudible] dot com slash
[inaudible] that's [inaudible] dot com
slash Burger for 20%
off your first order of
meanders.com/burr me undies me on
days. Give them to your brother Tom
[inaudible]. Buy a pair for your mom.
You like both of them cause you related.
Now that fucking crutches are ventilated.
Debbie, go. That was a better one. Yeah.
All right. I had to make up for that.
All right. Dollar Shave Club, stamps.com.
That's what I have left.
But let me go to the,
let me go to your questions for the week,
ladies and gentlemen,
the questions of the week.
Um, okay. Here we go.
Uh, bike race accident. Dear Bill,
did you see the video going
around this weekend of, uh,
of the Brooklyn bike race
pileup? No, I didn't. Uh,
it really makes you question the
hive mentality of those bikers.
I've been involved in some high speed
activities and their inability to stop or
slow down properly,
properly is mind blowing.
Give it a Google come down to
San Diego once in awhile. Um,
no I haven't seen that.
But uh,
I do know that people on a
regular basis fucking die.
I'm not on a regular basis. But
you definitely diamonds. Yeah.
The how fast those fucking guys goes.
Yeah.
You're riding a motorcycle
without an engine and I'm,
Oh, you get those fucking little
shorts on, get that road rash.
It's the exact same thing. It
minus the muffler burned. Uh,
but I actually am a big
fan of bike racing though.
I always used to watch the Tour de France
and I love watching lance wind fucking
seven in a row, which he did.
He wants seven in a rough. Okay.
Everybody from him all the way to
the back of the race tested positive.
So I'll never,
I'll never give up those seven.
I'll always that he wanted
those fucking things.
And I gotta tell you something right now.
I haven't watched it since then because
it's been boring without, you know,
it's like tiger woods ever since
his wife fucking flipped out on him.
You know, it took half his money.
The fucking guy isn't one shit.
And I never watch golf. I do
like Phil Mickelson though.
I like watching that guy,
that guy. He's like a, the guy fucking
goes for it. He doesn't give a shit.
He's like, yeah, you're behind
a tree. I don't give a fuck.
I'm going to slice right around this
thing. I'm going for the pin. Uh,
I don't know. Maybe you should lay
up. Hey, look at all this sweat.
I got into my man tits.
You think I'm laying up?
I'm already ready for a fucking
Arnold Palmer. I'm going for the pin.
It's what he does every time.
All right, drum workout. Hey sir,
billion big fan of the podcast and
thought I'd share this with you because I
know how much you love drums and
talking about working out. Um, oh yeah,
recently. Yeah. I don't know how
I, I, I missed out on pan terror.
I just, you know, I could never get
into that fucking type of singing,
you know what I mean? He's
like, Jesus Christ, I heard
this in my house growing up.
I, I don't music used to
take me away from this shit,
but just undeniably Vinnie Paul is one
of the great rock drums of all time
without a fucking doubt.
And I don't think he gets the credit.
I was talking to my drum teacher about
this where he's a lot like Alex van Halen,
who's another one of the
great drummers of all time,
but both of them like Alex never
got is do I feel because of Eddie.
Eddie was just so fucking insane that
everybody focused on him and they didn't
really even notice how great Alex was.
And I feel like pan
terrorists the same thing.
It's kind of creepy how like they
both have brothers, like, you know,
there were innovated, innovative, you
know, dying bag. The cab was just,
there was nobody liked either one
of those guitar players in fact.
And then you are else is fucked to
bring it full circle is unfortunately,
when Dimebag was murdered,
um,
I always heard that Eddie donated one of
his key loved Eddie van Halen and Eddie
donated one of his guitars.
Um,
I think it was that black and yellow one
and they actually buried with Dimebag.
So, uh, I don't know, it's kind of a
morbid way to go around and say, Vinnie,
Paul's a fucking amazing drummer. But,
um, I started listening to that song.
I'm broken and uh,
you know,
it's fucking killing me that I can't
just sit down and try to figure that
fucking song out. Cause I, you know, got
to sit in this fucking writer's room.
I'm really whining about
the writer's room, you know,
cause I'm used to just fucking have in
my days to myself to just sit around,
you know, staring at my dry me undies
balls. Um, all right, drum workouts.
So this new workout saw this new workout
where you pretend to play the drums,
which is currently available in
the La area. See the video link.
Wanted to hear your thoughts. Comment
on these modern gym classes these days.
Time to start soundproofing
that garage gym.
Thanks for la for the laughs
and go fuck yourself. Well why,
what I don't understand
like guitar hero or even,
I haven't even looked at
this fucking workout class.
Like why wouldn't you just
learn how to play drums? Oh,
they're not pretending to play
drums. They have sticks. Oh God.
Yeah.
Is this going to be white
people trying to be tribal?
Oh yeah.
It's sort of aerobics
and then just playing beats
with sticks and stuff.
Oh my God, this, Oh this
has given me Deuce Chels
ah.
They're like,
okay.
Oh God.
And they always has to be the person
wearing the hat inside the knitted hat.
Ah,
just when you thought
that awful look went away.
You know the guy with the fucking
skinny jeans, the t shirt and then like,
I'm going to have a snowball fight hat on.
I'm pretending to play the
drums is now a hot new workout.
Well they weren't really pretending.
They were actually hitting the floor with
them and stuff and hitting the sticks.
So he said there was already a
dance from form in India called
Dan. Yeah. Dan Dia,
which has the same concept of dancing
with sticks and a thousand plus years old
tradition. Oh, what a
surprise. What is surprised at?
Somebody already come up with a
little gift up, gets people in shape.
It actually kind of looks like fun,
but I my ears couldn't handle,
I'd have to have fucking earplugs in.
Um
hmm.
I Dunno, but everyone was making those
guitar hero rocket, rocket out faces.
But what would be cool is
if that actually, you know,
if you take one of those classes and
you actually want to learn how to play
drums, but you know, you can't really
play because you have an apartment.
I cannot recommend those Rolling v
drums enough. They're fucking amazing.
And uh,
I told you when I had to two of
those kits when I was in New York,
it's kind of weird because
it's like a computer,
like it gets old and then the new one's
better than you. Like, cause you know,
if it was an acoustic,
like a regular drum kit,
you just keep it from the fucking drums.
But they get the new brains and they're
better. And I don't know, you just keep,
just keep, I don't know.
It's a lot of fucking money,
but they're fucking awesome.
So if you live,
if you live like the way I did where
I had a neighbor underneath me,
I went downstairs and I knocked
on the guys doing, I said, listen,
I practice drums. Uh, when do you work?
I'll only practice during those hours.
If you're ever home. When I'm
practicing, here's my phone number,
call me the second I pick up, you tell me
to stop. I will immediately stop. And we,
uh,
we actually still had a problem because
the first time you heard me play and he,
I said, hello. He goes,
can you knock it off?
And I just fucking snapped on the guy. I
was like, dude, don't fucking say that.
Like you asked me 12 fucking times.
It did all that shit.
And then he never called me again
fucking dickhead. Although you know,
in defense of him, I can't imagine what
that sounded like underneath, you know,
not Jesus. I'm just fucking,
I'm just, just for attracting
every fucking statement.
Alright, shoot matches.
Dear Billy bangers and Mash,
you were talking about shoot, mashes,
shoot matches on this Thursday's podcast.
For those of you who didn't listen,
uh,
shoot match is a wrestling
term where basically, you know,
the sports entertainment,
you know,
it's a fake fight even though they
really hurting each other, but you know,
it's worked out.
It's sports entertainment.
So technically it's fake even though
they're really throwing each other and
getting hurt, it is fake. Um,
what happens in a shoot match is somebody
fucking snaps and becomes a real fight
and starts beating the shit
out of the person for real. So,
um, he said if you're
into those shoot matches,
you should definitely look
up a wrestler name New Jack.
The psycho was known for frequently
shooting on other wrestlers for the most
minor things.
In one case,
he thought a tag team was trying
to steal his gangster image.
So he hit them with chairs,
full force,
stabbed them in the head with forks,
it's Cetera. And another match.
He basically tries to murder
a 60 something year old man.
Those matches are brutal as fuck man.
You should check them out.
I actually saw those. Yeah, that
guy has like psychological damages,
damages, psychological damage. Um,
I knew a guy liked that when I was
growing up. He went to fucking cops.
School surprise, surprise.
You know, fucking maniacs.
You like to be violent. Like they always
end up somehow being bouncers and cops.
I'm not saying they're all like that.
I'm just saying it's like, you know,
people that want to fuck kids,
you know,
they're all about volunteering
to take them out into the woods.
Not saying every cub scout master
as well. I'm just saying, you know,
people who want to beat the fuck out
of people in don't want to go to jail,
get jobs where they have the authority
to beat the fuck out of somebody.
So this fucking lunatic.
So he comes back from like his
weekend at cops school and um,
I don't know what he did
and he never got accepted.
They just were like try out thing.
I don't know.
I can't remember was so fucking long ago.
So he wants to show me this move that
he learned and he was doing it in slow
motion. And then I remember
he just fucking looked up
at the ceiling, you know?
Do you remember how like, uh, that dude
in full metal jacket when he's like,
I am in a world of shit.
Try the joker, you know,
that, that thing, right.
He fucking looked up like that and
just fucking full force did the move.
And I heard my fucking wrist snap and um,
I forget how many times I punched
him in the side of the head.
I was so fucking mad at him and I was
really just mad at myself because I knew
that he was one of those guys,
like he just fucking like,
like he was one of those key was one of
the exact type of personality that you
do not teach that type of shit too.
Because just
he was a dope.
He never felt like he had power in life
and then he had this new move and he
just couldn't handle it.
It was like,
you know the whole thing when they always
talk like a baby poisonous snake is
the worst, is worse than getting
bit by an adult baby snake.
Cause he dealt babies,
snakes sort of rations out.
The poison with the baby just gives
you fucking both barrels. That's,
that's what the fuck he did. He had the
mentality of a fucking baby reptiles.
What I'm saying?
And he fucking jacked up
my goddamn wrist and hey,
and you know what? It became
a fucking shoot match. That
was probably as positive.
Show it to me and I just fucking
drilled him in the side of the head like
fucking six times is
hard as I fucking could.
I was so fucking mad at him and
I remember we were both drunk.
Yeah.
Yeah. Fucking idiot. God bless him.
Um, anyways, moving ahead here.
That was a throwback Thursday story.
All right. Fight dear Billy boy band.
Billy boy band. All right.
Everyone's been asked.
Everyone's always asking for
advice. So here's a rhetorical, uh,
who's,
who wins in a fight to the death between
a silver back gorilla and a grizzly
bear.
One's got Iq and Matt upper body,
the other has razor sharp
claws and skull crushing jars.
Uh, thanks, uh,
and go sit on it repeatedly.
And I don't know what that means.
Is that like a happy
days, rest reference? Um,
I would say,
uh,
it depends on if it's a high,
I'm rooting.
I would go with the home team.
All right.
If it's a home game for the grizzly bear
and they're out in an open field and
there's no fucking tree for the gorilla
to fucking go up and then come back
down,
go up.
You don't do that fucking monkey shit
where they slap you in the fucking head.
Um, I would, I would say
the grizzly wins because
you know, the gorillas can ball up its
fists, but you know, you're fighting,
it's like you fight and Freddy Krueger
and he's got two gloves for gloves.
Actually, I would say. Um,
yeah,
I dunno. And I got to admit, like
I think, I think grill is a chill,
like I don't think they really
like doing that stuff. And, um,
I've watched him fight other
fucking gorillas and, uh,
you know,
there's a lot of clutching and grabbing
and shit and I've watched two gorilla
grizzly bears go at it and it's
fucking devastating. Where you like,
how was one of them not dead?
So I would say a grizzly bear.
Um,
I don't know.
And I'm sure over in Asia that they
have those fights on the weekends
somewhere in Asia. They're
doing that right now. Um,
because when I go on Youtube, I'm
just basing that on, you know,
where you go on Youtube is actually
black and white footage of like lions
fighting tigers and shit like that and
fucking cobras fighting these things and
you know,
it's not an alligator's first
fucking cobras or whatever
the fuck they was. Just,
you know, like over in Asia,
like the original MMA, you know,
UFC type of shit was actually
animals versus animals, you know.
I mean, you've got to give it up
to them. I mean, I know that we,
we ask those questions here over in Asia,
they actually get it done. You know,
which makes means that they're actually
killing it more in the realm of a,
don't tell me. Show me that. Taking
the initiative is all I'm saying.
Um, all right. Here we go. We get
a couple more here. All right. Um,
let me read the last two.
Fucking advertising's really quick.
Advertising's advertisements.
Jesus Christ.
It's amazing. An amazing sometimes that,
that English is my first language. Uh,
by the way, I'm 64 days in with my
French. I'm learning past tense stuff.
I can look at it and I can translate it,
but I can't recall it because I have
no one to speak it with. But, uh,
I have to think that it's
helping me on some level.
I think I'll be able to read a newspaper
by the time I get to fucking France the
next time. I just won't be
able to talk to anybody. Um,
whatever. I'll feel I'll figure something
out. All right. Dollar Shave Club.
Uh, you guys, I figured it out. I've
discovered the key to an amazing shave.
It's simple. Is this me talking right
now? Okay, I'm sorry. Hey you guys.
I figured it out.
It's simple.
That's exactly what dollar shave club.com
does and why I'm a proud member like
millions of others. I'm not a member
now cause I don't like them. I just,
I can't deal with fucking trying to sign
up for shit cause even if I sign up for
it eventually I'm going to
lose my fucking password and I,
and she's a fucking nightmare.
A dollar shave club.com delivers amazing
razors right to my door for a third of
the price of what you get from
those greedy razor corporations, um,
which is true both, uh, your wallet
and face. Finally, get some relief.
Joined Dollar Shave club.com means you
can afford to shave with a fresh blade
anytime you want, which feels fucking
amazing. And for the smoothest shave ever,
use your fresh dollar shave club,
a blade with doctor cabbies. Easy.
Dr Carver's, easy shave butter. Uh,
it's not your average shave cream.
It's high quality ingredients that
make your skin feel soft and smooth and
moisturized. Your blade. We'll just
glide gently across your skin. Um,
if you want the, the, the most amazing
shape possible, take it from me.
Use a fresh dollar shave club
blade and Dr Carver's shave butter.
Um,
uh,
two reasons to join Denise to say
easy shave butter. Dr Carver's.
Easy shave butter.
Now it's Dr Carver's shave butter.
Anyways, two two reasons to join the
dollar shave club.com/bird today. Uh,
that style is dollar shave
club.com/bar. Um, all right,
sorry. The fucking dyslexia
is really kicking it today.
One of my eyes is on the word I'm reading
and the other one is like three words
down. I don't know what that is. What
is the medical term for that? Uh,
Lazy. I'd all right. stamps.com ah,
the old favorites as Americans celebrate
as America celebrates National Small
Business Week this week, stamps.com
wants to honor, not only,
it's over 600,000 small
business customers.
stamps.com also wants to
extend an invitation to small
businesses throughout the
nation to help their businesses succeed
by reducing or eliminating wasteful
trips to the post office. stamps.com
knows that one of the most available,
most valuable resources as
a small business is time.
You can't waste it making constant trips
to the post office for your mailing and
shipping.
That's why stamps.com brings all the
services of the post office right to your
desk.
Uh,
you can buy and print official US
postage for any letter in a package,
any class that mail by using your
computer or printer over 600,000 small
businesses are already using stamps.com.
You should try it too.
I use stamps.com dissent
on any of my posters.
Anytime I'm whoring myself out
after my shows, I'm a moron.
If I can figure out how could how
to do it. So can you right now,
sign up for stamps.com and use my last
name bur bur for this special offer,
four week trial plus $110 bonus offer,
including postage and a digital scale.
Don't wait. Go to stamps.com before
you do anything else, click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinbarthatstamps.com
enter
burr
are
right.
Here we go. And, uh, what do I got here?
I've got the questions. The last two here.
All right, Tom Brady and Jim, or say,
all right, even I'm sick of this fucking
story at this point. What are Billy boy,
big fan of you by blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah.
Of course the patch didn't beat the
colts by 34 because of a deflated ball,
deflated balls. That's not the
point though. Here's an example.
If a baseball player
is on steroid but goes,
oh for five on a particular day, what do
you mean? That's not the point though.
I don't know what point you made.
MMM.
I guess you're saying the deflated ball
didn't affect the outcome of a baseball
player is on steroids, but goes,
oh, for five on a particular day.
Does that mean he didn't cheat?
Of course not.
I hate people who do this
who ask questions for me. Uh,
the point I'm making is that
it's not about the results.
It's about breaking the rules. See,
this is why I can't stand people.
That's not, this is not what that
decision was about Tom Brady's was,
was his suspension was reinstated.
Not because it was proven that he cheated.
This last trial was all about does it
corporation have a right to discipline?
It's employee.
That's what it was about.
That's what the NFL was fighting.
Cause Tom Brady opened up a can of worms,
which was basically like where your
boss and we said you're suspended.
He appealed it outside of
the NFL into a court of law,
which of course it didn't fucking hold
up cause it was a complete kangaroo court
for shit fucking thing that happened.
Okay.
You know where the owner of the other
fucking team hires a guy to find dirt on
the other fucking team, which
you can do on anybody. Right.
And then then one guy plays judge,
jury and execution.
You take it into a court of law.
I knew that thing would get laughed
out of court, which had fucking did.
And Jim Irsay was looked to be a fucking
moron. So then what happened, sir,
is they changed their argument.
They then went back to say, listen,
we are the NFL, the corporation known
as the national football league.
Tom Brady is an employee. All
right? We said that he's suspended.
We are his boss.
Do we w we,
we argue that we have the right
to suspend our own employees.
That's what it was about.
Okay.
So this is what kills me about all these
people, including Michael [inaudible],
Michael Rappaport who texted me,
right?
He fucking texted me and he goes,
hi mother fucker.
Guilty until proven innocent.
Like, like Tom Brady was recess.
Like this suspension was reactivated,
thus vindicating everybody that says,
Tom Brady's a cheat.
You guys are not paying attention to the
fucking story. That's not what happened.
What happened was the NFL in a court of
law one the right to suspend Tom Brady
because Tom Brady is a fucking,
oh God.
Is there anything more relentless than
when your fucking wife calls Jesus Christ?
I've got two more minutes here.
Um, all right, I'll answer it here.
Hang on a second. I'll answer it. Hello.
Hello. It's connecting. Hey,
I'm finishing my podcast.
That's why I have a microphone
and headphones on. I'll
try acquire right back.
Qt By. Um, anyways,
that's what happens. So I'll
read the rest of this guy. Shit.
Most buffalo wild wings dopes.
Think what happened was the, uh,
the NFL appealed it and it got proven
that Tom Brady is in fact a cheater.
That that was never proven. It
was never proven. All right,
so I don't know what, so he
goes, if Brady broke the rule,
then he should be punished.
I don't know if he did or he didn't.
I'm just tired of the argument that
sends pads, the pads blew out the colts.
It doesn't matter.
Another thing,
you always say that the colts owner
got rules changed to benefit his teams.
What rules were changed?
As far as I know,
he only asked that the league enforce
rules that were already in place.
Now we sat on the rules committee
when we beat him and we
roughed up as receivers,
he bitched to the referees and
the referee said that's illegal.
He then made a tape,
he and a and Peyton manning made a tape,
went to the NFL and the NFL said,
that's legal.
Jim Irsay got on the rules committee.
He spearheaded a movement to make the way
we covered their receivers, not legal.
Okay. The cold set a better
offense than we did at the time.
We had a better defense. He made a rule
change that tipped it in favor of him.
This guy is fucking filthy.
He's fucking filthy.
Those laws were changed.
And why do I have to tell you that?
Why don't you fucking look it up like
you can't find it anyways, he goes,
as far as I know, he only
asked for the no. Yeah,
as far as you know yet
because you didn't look it up.
The five yard rule for receivers has
been around forever. No, it hasn't.
No, it hasn't. That
happened in my lifetime.
The first thing that was
was the Mel blunt rule.
When he beat the shit out
of Golden Richards in the
super bowl. Don't fuck you.
You're speaking in general out of these.
I can't fucking,
I can't stand people like this. Oh,
and it's been around for rubber. Oh,
this global blue. Oh, the, the,
they don't even look it up.
That's like version one verse. He
fucking goes like, uh, you know,
Joe Montana had Jerry Rice.
It's like he didn't have him
for his first two super bowls.
He had nobody in 81 he had
Freddy Solomon and Dwight Clark.
Those were his number one and two
receivers. And he had some guy,
Earl Cooper is a fucking running back.
He won with nobody. He won with people.
But you want to start one of the
people he won't stars, right?
Fucking millennials. I don't understand
that. Wherever the pre millennials,
they just don't look at any of them.
He said Earth or say
simply wanted it enforced.
What's wrong with that? Please respond
on your podcast. Even if you shit on me,
I'll remain a listen or you're
funny, mother Fucker, Dude.
That's not what fucking happened. And
all of this shit happen in your lifetime.
You're just having selective memory.
He fucking, he said to the
referee's, look at this tape.
Look what they did. They go,
yeah, we saw it. That's legal.
Unreal. Unreal. And then they
made the tape, how do you
forget this shit? There was,
it was like a little over 10 years ago.
Go look it up.
That's what the fuck happened. And
then it became, then it became,
you can't touch them at all.
It wasn't after five yards.
It wasn't before the five yards.
You're touching moves after them.
The physical contact that they were
having after that that they were bitching
about, and then that's when it came,
okay, you can do the five yard chuck.
And then after that bullshit,
you can't touch anybody at all.
Used to be able to handshake. I'm not
saying like, you know that, you know,
10 years ago you could fucking beat the
shit out of me. I'm not saying that,
but it's gradually kept moving towards
what Jim Irsay finally had was like,
okay, you can push the guy, you know,
in the first five yards and then this
is the gym or the gym or say ruled that
his men after that you can't do anything.
Okay.
Which is why right after that,
all of a sudden all of Dan Marino's
records started falling right and left.
I remember one year there was
like drew bullies, drew Brees,
Peyton manning and like fucking Tom
Brady were all on pace to break his like
almost 30 year old record.
Yes. Yards in a season. Um,
yeah,
because of those,
those ridiculous things that we became
almost a legal to cover a receiver.
It was never like that when I was growing
up ever. And if you don't believe me,
do your homework, go look,
go look at old NFL footage.
This shit that you could do.
The NBA is the same fucking way you could
beat the shit out of somebody if they
came down the fucking lane. I mean,
what Kevin Mchale did, the Kurt Rambis,
I mean back in the [inaudible] data, that
would be like a 10 game suspension, um,
or whatever it would be. You'd be
suspended for a number of games in it.
And as far as I know, nobody
even got thrown out. Uh,
but I am going back like 30 years,
so please just,
I don't give a fuck if you want to shit
on my team, but just do your homework.
That last trial was about a corporation's
right to suspend an employee.
That's what it was about. It wasn't about
whether Tom Brady was guilty. And, uh,
and for all you concept out there who
are just obsessed with this air pressure,
what if Tom Brady had fucking steroids
delivered to his fucking mailbox in his
wife's name? Give me a fucking
break already. And even then,
I gotta be honest with you.
I don't think steroids changed
the outcome of the game.
They help your personal performance.
But if steroids just met you won the game,
then you know, teams that did
steroids, they're there, but they,
when they just go on defeated.
Yeah,
okay.
I Dunno. It gives you a competitive
edge. It does. And you know, whatever, I,
I am not against steroids. I think
steroids should be fucking legalize.
They should be researched
to the hilt and um,
just for literally for the quality of
life then everyone's going to have,
I can't,
I mean singers blow out their voices,
they get to take a steroid and they
go out to sing the fucking song.
There'll be in the crowd says
that they cheated. Right. I Dunno.
Anyways, what's flower head?
Whatever. I'm, I'm fucking,
I'm done arguing that especially at this
point when all of that information that
I just said is out there.
I might've had a couple of things wrong
cause I don't have the literally the
documents in front of me.
But basically what I'm saying is true
and I just don't want to argue this shit
anymore. Okay. No matter what,
this guy's going to get suspended.
Cause at the end of the day he
works with his fucking corporation.
And you know what the
NFL is actually right.
I think they're wrong to suspend
Tom Brady. I think that the,
the investigation and all of that
was an absolute fucking witch hunt.
I think all of that is bullshit.
But I do think that the NFL is a
corporation has to maintain the right to
suspend somebody. So if the bus has
to roll over Tom Brady, then so be it.
Cause it's gonna make for a better
league because if he gets away with this,
then everybody is going to appeal it
outside of the NFL and then they lose
control. And as much as I'm not a
fan of monopolies, as a sports fan,
it works out great. Like the UFC is to
shit because the fighters have no options.
I feel bad for those guys,
but it's great for me as a fight fan
because the best guys have to fight the
best guys. Um, all right. Advice.
I smell. All right. I have a car.
I have a crippling health issues
since I was a kid. I fucking stink.
People tell me I smell moldy.
No doctor knows why Colone deodorants
can't mask it. Oh my God. He goes,
the odor actually gets stronger when I
use those things. Showering doesn't help.
So I am left alone with the this issue
I'm trying to eat as healthy as possible
and exercise every day,
which seems to reduce the problem by 50%,
which sounds like a lot but
still doesn't satisfy me.
I think it's a metabolic issue,
which I don't even know what that is.
And the body is trying to get rid
of the toxins through the skin.
Not sure though,
either way.
My whole life revolves around this
shit and it led me through episodes of
depression as a teenager and I even
considered throwing myself off a bridge or
in front of one of those
great white trains, uh,
US Germans are making,
but life is actually
decent despite this issue.
I can't attend any college
classes because of the anxiety,
but I have a great amount of friends.
I'm happy, funny, alright. Looking Guy.
And my game is all right. So I still
get my dick wet. Sometimes gross. Uh,
can't lock down any girl
though for obvious reasons.
I don't even know why I wrote all of this,
but I just wanted to tell you that
this podcast and your comedy are really
stimulating.
My Butt's thinking brain,
please come to Germany so we can see
your show and I can harass you nose.
Thanks for reading and go fuck
yourself and your dog. Just kidding.
I like your dog. Just go fuck
yourself. I'm all right dude. Um,
I would just keep going
to doctors if they,
I bet they could figure something out.
You know,
it's gotta be some new agey type of thing,
some sort of detox.
If it's your body getting rid of a toxic,
maybe you're allergic to something.
I have no idea. I am not, obviously
not a doctor here, but yeah.
Okay.
Detox, fasting, changing your diet.
Um, there's gotta be, there's
gotta be a way to do that.
I remember long time ago,
there was some woman that just had,
was talking about she had brutal
Halitosis, which is, uh, you know,
you breads fucking stinks. It
was fucking brutal. And, um,
it turned out she had some sort of sinus
infection and then once they cleared
that up for fucking, her breath
was fine. So I bet you have.
Yeah,
I, you know, if I had to guess,
there's something undiagnosed,
you know. Oh God, I'm so in over my head.
You got something maybe that you
have some sort of fucking infection.
I have no fucking idea. And I bet you know
there's gotta be something that is if,
if, if somebody can take a nap and
drive to work and not kill anybody,
they got to figure out why your moldy.
I would just keep going
to specialists and I,
if you guys have nationwide
healthcare over there, I would just,
that would be my new hobby,
you know,
and just keep adding to your file and
somebody comes in and somebody will
finally crack the fucking case
as to why you smelled moldy.
I bet they can figure it out,
you know?
And then what would be great is you
went to the alienation of this. See,
you got the sense of humor that
comes from feeling alienated and um,
I, your life will be a fucking joke
after that. I mean, think about it too.
If you could just stop smelling moldy,
I would think that that's the number
one thing. And then you'd be happy.
You live your life would
be at fucking joke.
So if you have nationwide healthcare,
I would be seeing a doctor like fucking
every couple of days. All right buddy.
It's like you're pulling people out of
the crowd. He hit the half court shot.
Eventually it's, the ball's going to
go in, I believe in June. It's fuel.
It's fucking Germany. You guys
got you guys a fucking, you know,
half our space program we stole from
you guys. The whole seeds of it.
Audio tape, all that shit. You guys
had better machine guns that we did.
Ours would overheat. Sophie
killed you. We actually picked,
we dropped our guns and
picked up your machine.
Guns is no fucking way in 2016 they
can't figure out why your moldy.
I feel bad for you,
man.
I'm rooting for you and I hope you figure
it out before you come out to my shelf
and a, I should probably know the answer
if they didn't, you know. All right,
go fuck yourselves. I have a great
weekend. I'll check in on you on Thursday.
Let's see you.